[Musique]
après le sujet des violences policières
son nouveau cheval de bataille et le
féminisme et le moins que l'on puisse
dire c'est que camélia jordana ne fait
pas dans la dentelle
dans une interview accordée au magazine
paris match la jeune chanteuse a décidé
de s'en prendre à deux icônes catherine
deneuve et brigitte bardot deux actrices
qui ces dernières années ont plutôt
dénoncer les mouvements féministes trop
engagé un refus de s'engager qui n'est
pas du goût de camélia jordana qui a
déclaré à leur sujet elle n'était pas le
symbole du féminisme elle incarnait la
femme parce qu'elles étaient des muses
l'antiféminisme par excellence avant
d'ajouter elles ont aussi vécu avec
l'idée que se prendre une main au cul et
est quelque chose de normal voire de
sympathiques
tout est là un coup d'oeil qui une fois
encore a fait grand bruit qui ne
manquera pas de faire réagir les deux
intéressés alors êtes vous d'accord avec
le coup de gueule de camélia jordana
[Musique]
moi je trouve que camélia jordana elle a
beaucoup de talent en tant que chanteuse
beaucoup de talent en tant qu'actrice
qu'est-ce qu'elle a besoin de donner son
avis sur tous les sujets d'actualité
comme ça systématiquement franchement
c'est insupportable en bus en disant
n'importe quoi et ce genre de propos ce
genre de phrase ça mais un climat de
tension entre les hommes et les femmes
c'est insupportable nous les aimons de
ce pur et à faire on veut plus rien dire
on a pu rien faire donc franchement
qu'elle chantait qu'elle joue la comédie
qui est très sympathique mais beaucoup
de gagnants
qu'est ce que vous diriez vous parce que
vous connaissez brigitte bardot
catherine de cette époque là cette
époque là c'est vrai que c'était c'était
différent une relation vam était
différente et les actrices quand elle se
faisait balader les gars étaient plus
insistants idée qu'il y avait des gros
lourdaud et relooke huahine d'airolo
voilà alors maintenant dire que non je
suis pas du tout d'accord et puis c'est
vrai ça manque de respect pour ceux des
femmes ont plus à qui savait très bien
se défendre tout seul et c'est non si
ridicule et c'est il a raison de
guillaume c'est qu'aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'elle est là la barrière
entre eux une voix la courtiser une
femme s'appelle séduire le jeu de la
séduction
on va maintenant penser ce qu'on fait
c'est ce qu'ont fait pas ça mais voila
ca c'est un vrai c'est un vrai pro de
moscou c'est très embêtant même si
évidemment il faut condamner sévèrement
les déplacés envers les femmes sur adsl
aimerions fait elle aime rien de notre
pays la france elle n'aime pas son passé
là bas sont présents à la passe en
l'avenir
elle doit être très très malheureuse ce
qu'effectivement voilà on est un pays
raciste pour camilla jordana
les policiers sont tous violents est en
fait l con elle elle en fait elle
condamne le racisme de notre prix en
étant soi disant anti racisme et l aile
et l'eau
du racisme en étant comme ça après tout
quand elle quand elle dit que les autres
sont des anti féministe mais est ce que
moi je vais du féminisme de camélia
jordana est ce que je veux que les
femmes soient toujours victimiser soit
toujours des petites choses comme ça
donc voilà donc moi je trouve qu'elle
voit elle dérape et vous savez qu'elle a
dit un truc super g elle a dit ce week
end dans le brio le fil où elle a eu le
césar avec daniel auteuil un sublime
film qu'elle regrettait presque d'avoir
fait ce film c'est la fameuse quand
celle que tu es parce qu'elle joue une
petite étudiante instrumentalisé par par
un grand professeur jolie je le confirme
cela compte salle culturelle
d'accord il ce que vient de dire
géraldine et en plus ce sont des sommes
qui étaient totalement libre entre
guillemets c'est à dire c'est à une plus
que des féministes j'allais bien faire
elle n'acceptera aucune si elle avait
décidé d'accepter une main au cul mais
par ailleurs un mec qui ne leur plaisait
pas le peuvent eux aussi bien alors
retourné une claque que donc c'est les
femmes qui savaient parfaitement
s'assumer donc elle a une méconnaissance
totale du type de femme comme bardot ou
d'un homme c'est clair penser qu'elle
est dans la grande salle culte moi
j'aimerais savoir qui rédige l'est le la
bible du féminisme parce que moi j'ai
l'impression qu'à chaque nana à son
féminisme à elle a fait ça veut dire que
elle elle parle pour elle son féminisme
mais c'est pas une raison pour
globaliser un petit peu moins tout ce
qu'on voit dans la vie et tout ce qui
s'est passé dans le panneau surtout que
ces deux nanas que ce soit catherine
deneuve ou brigitte bardot vous avez vu
les caractères qu'elles ont cessé
vraiment une trace à doha tienne tu
aimerais qu on dit quoi elle rassure à
tort parce qu'en plus il aura bien
insultante avec des hommes donc un
moment donné il va falloir réagir jeu si
allal je comprends les mecs on leur a
appris depuis qu'ils sont nés qui
doivent être les plus forts les plus
brillants ceux qui ont le plus de
pouvoir le plus gros sexe la plus grande
maison la plus grosse voiture je veux
dire à la péta un moule rate n'attendez
rien donné c'est caricatural histoire
d'éducation à bien des hommes et éduquer
sur des rebonds la majorité mais ça veut
dire et ça c' est ce à ce genre de
phrase ça fait partie d'un nouveau truc
qui émergent
les spectateurs aujourd'hui cet été
c'est comme ça chez moi ça allait non
c'est juste qu'elle n'est jamais
contente de rien géraldine là dit elle
aime rien elle elle est jeune elle
arrive moi j'adore guillaume a dit
grande actrice et grande chanteuse
allait effectivement elle chante très
bien
l'actrice à domicile j'écoute ses
chansons et je la donne je ne devrais
juste chanter et se taire parce qu'à
chaque fois elle divise pour rien du
tout elle devrait respecter deneuve jane
birkin et bardot pour leur carrière tu
viens d'arriver fais ta carrière chante
respecte les anciens ils étaient là
avant là ça sert à rien tu rhône qui
rentrent dans des faux combat parce que
là où je suis encore plus énervé l'adar
fois lavé les faisant la police elle
avait dit que tous les matins il y avait
des flics qui massacrer des gens et dans
les quartiers ou ailleurs et c'était
pendant une promo est là elle reparle
d'elle et elle est encore encore en
promo d'albums dont camélia chante comme
le comme les footballeurs jouent au foot
et parle pas certains footballeurs il
devrait parler il devrait jouer au foot
et se taire baal est fait pour son
voleur